On February 27, Paramount+ treated viewers
to an absolute pile of heartache and devastation
with the tenth episode of "1883," "This Is
Not Your Heaven."
Though the episode feels very much like a
season finale, if not a series finale, the
network has thus far declined to call its
officially-ordered future episodes a "second
season."
This has led some to speculate that it's not,
technically, a finale of either kind.
Whichever way you slice it, the immediate
narrative presented to viewers in the series'
first 10 episodes came to a gut-wrenching
conclusion on Sunday, with a scene that parallels
an equally moving moment in Season 1 of its
predecessor series, "Yellowstone."
Despite audiences knowing from the series'
very first scene that the formidable Elsa
Dutton was destined to be struck by an arrow,
her slow demise as a result of her wound in
Episode 10 still came as a shock.
As Elsa slowly dies, her father James pulls
her down from her horse, drags her over to
a tree, and cradles his daughter in his lap
as the two share a final exchange.
Whether or not fans felt the scene a fitting
end to Elsa's story, it was, as some have
noted, a fitting match with "Yellowstone's"
recurring themes.
As fans of "Yellowstone" will recall, the
pilot concluded with a similarly heartbreaking
moment between John Dutton and his recently-deceased
eldest son, Lee.
After lowering Lee's corpse off his horse,
the Dutton patriarch drags his body over to
a tree so he can share a final embrace with
his son, rest awhile, and choose a spot for
his burial.
A small, loud bird interrupts their time together
and serves as a kind of symbolism for the
themes of the scene.
As one user pointed out on the series' subreddit,
John and his great-grandfather are "both sitting
against a tree with their deceased children,
both with a bird."
Other fans were quick to note the similarity,
with one user adding that both scenes involve
a character saying they want to "rest for
a bit."
There are some differences, but for the most
part, the scenes are almost perfect replications
of one another.
By ending the first 10 episodes of "1883,"
a prequel to the events that take place during
"Yellowstone," on the same exact note upon
which the latter essentially begins, the creators
of the series have once again foregrounded
the cyclical nature of life, death, and the
struggle that lies in between.
The death of a popular character is usually
enough to send fans up in arms, but since
Elsa's fate is telegraphed by design, "1883"
viewers have had the chance to brace themselves
for quite a while.
When the inevitable end comes, and the viewer
notices that the show has no intention of
saving the character in some far-fetched fashion,
many viewers found that they actually liked
the way the show handled her death.
One Twitter user wrote,
"I love how Elsa didn't just pass away and
that was it.
We were able to see her happy and know that
she was OK.
Completely unexpected yet amazing writing.
Death is so final and leaves you empty.
They managed to not leave us, me anyway, with
that."
Another user found the character and her fate
both realistic and compelling.
"Why am I so upset about Elsa in 1883?
I think I would mourn her death like she wasn't
a fictional character!"
Another user tweeted a theory that Elsa's
death might be the first in a long line of
tragedies that Lee's death ties into, and
that Yellowstone 1932 will also feature a
chilling death in the family.
"John Dutton, in 'Yellowstone', says numerous
times that he made a promise to never sell
the ranch.
I'm sure that when 1932 airs about John Duttons
father and grandfather we see this "promise"
made from one generation to the next, and
it all starts with Elsa Dutton's death in
1883."
"He says it's wrong for one man to own all
this.
He says you should share it with all the people."
"Yeah?"
Could it be that the Duttons have paid the
price of their ranch in blood?
It's a chilling idea, and it will indeed be
interesting to see whether the upcoming "1932"
addresses it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.